[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
--starting, welcome.
This session is the world
record of Pi calculation.
We calculated 31.4
trillion digits.
My name is Emma.
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
And--
ALEX YEE: And I'm Alex Yee,
high performance computing
specialist.
Just curious-- how many
of you out here know
me either personally
or online or who have
used y-cruncher in the past?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Have you
OK, so.
ALEX YEE: OK, cool.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Cool, nobody.
[LAUGHTER]
We have Dory.
It's an online service
to ask questions.
There is a link from your app.
So if you open the session,
you have a link to Dory.
Feel free to put your
question, upvote.
We also have a microphone,
live questions.
We're going to take
questions later.
So we announced this
achievement on Pi Day this year.
We cooperative 31.4 trillion
digits on Google Cloud.
So today's talk is
about-- so we're
going to take a brief
look at the history of Pi.
And then we're going to
explain how we did this.
And then we'll explain the
technical details, y-cruncher,
the program we used, itself.
And later, we have a
section for our future work.
So let's take a
look at the history
of Pi and the computers.
So as Donald E. Knuth, the
author of "the Art of Computer
Programming," said in his book,
human progress in calculation
has traditionally been
measured by the number
of decimal digits of Pi.
So humanity, as
collectively, has
tried to calculate
as many digits of Pi
as possible since 2000 BC.
And since the 1400s, we found
the equation to calculate Pi.
And since then, we were able
to calculate Pi separate
from the geometric features.
And then, in 1949, we used the
very first electronic computer,
ENIAC, to calculate Pi.
So they did 2037 digits.
And ever since then, we
use Pi as the benchmark
for supercomputers.
And the last record was in 2009.
And the yellow on-- it's hard to
see, but the record by Bellard
was the very first record
on a desktop computer.
And then the previous record in
2016 was Peter Trueb and Alex.
They did 23 trillion digits.
And we did 31
trillion this year.
This is the first world
record done on cloud.
ALEX YEE: So there are two
forms of Pi computation.
And we want to differentiate
between the two.
First of all, it is to compute
all the digits from the start
to end.
So if you want to compute
a trillion a year,
you want to compute from 3.14159
all the way to the 1 trillionth
digit.
This is the most commonly
talked about Pi computation.
It is very memory intensive
because of the amount
of digits involved.
The current world record is
the one that we just set,
31.4 trillion digits
by me and Emma.
The other form of
computation is to compute
a small number of
binary digits of Pi
at a specific
offset N. This type,
it uses a negligible
amount of memory usage.
So it's embarrassingly parallel.
And the current record is 10
to the 17th hexadecimal digit
by Joseph Takahasi last year.
This method is also used
to verify the computation
of the first type.
Challenges to competing Pi--
so computing many digits of Pi
is extremely memory intensive.
At the current record frontier,
we're at 31 trillion digits.
It requires hundreds of
terabytes of memory to compute.
Communication, memory
access, is the bottleneck.
It's so bad that computational
power doesn't actually
matter anymore.
This latest computation that
we had, 31 trillion digits,
actually had an
8 to 1 bottleneck
on disk I/O. The sustained CPU
usage averaged about 12.2%.
In other words, the
computation, the amount of work
to do computationally,
is actually negligible
compared to the disk I/O.
So why is computing so many
digits so memory intensive?
This is actually
quite complicated.
But to oversimplify
things a little bit,
there's a very low computation
to communication ratio.
The runtime complexity,
the computational work,
is O(N*log(N)^3).
But communication is
actually O(N*log(N)^2).
So there's only a log N ratio.
By comparison, a lot of
dense linear algebra stuff
tend to be linear
or even higher.
And this is exacerbated
by the memory wall.
So for the past few
decades, as some of you
or whatever you know,
the performance gap
between the CPU and memory has
been increasing exponentially.
And it doesn't just
apply to memory.
It also applies to disk.
And so in this age, the
only thing that matters
is the disk I/O efficiency.
So the graph, the
picture on the right,
is actually a run in the
middle of a sample computation.
The bottom row here
is the disk I/O usage.
And you can see that
it's completely saturated
at about 3 gigs a second.
In the top is the CPU usage.
And it's spiky.
It's not sustained
because the whole time
it is waiting on the disk I/O.
So challenges, PC computations--
PCs are not very powerful.
It's just one machine.
They have a limited
amount of memory.
So you can't really go
much more than, maybe,
a couple of hundred
gigs of memory.
And so the picture on
the top is actually my PC
that I built in 2014,
not that impressive.
So because PCs
aren't very powerful,
you need to run them
for a very long time.
And for computations
this large, you actually
need to use disk because you
can't fit 100 terabytes of data
onto a PC.
And so the usage of
disk to do computation
is called out of core computing.
I will get to that later.
Supercomputers-- they have
a different set of problems.
First of all, they're expensive.
And they have limited access.
Access tends to be limited
to those who are in academia
or those who work closely
with them in the industry.
Secondly, they're more
difficult to program for.
It's not just one machine.
There are many machines.
So you have to do with
communication, parallels.
And there's a lot different
topologies for supercomputers.
Nevertheless, supercomputers
can actually still run.
But as of this date, there are
no publicly available programs
to actually do it.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
And now, we want
to talk about the overview
of our architecture
and calculation.
So as we said, this is the
first record now on cloud.
We calculated 10
[INAUDIBLE] trillion digits.
Pi times 10 powered by 13.
And we spent 121 digits.
As we said, we use the
program called y-cruncher.
And we use one main
compute node with 96 vCPUs
with 1.4 terabytes of RAM.
And I think one of the
most interesting statistics
is we read nine petabytes
of read and 8 petabytes of--
we wrote 8 petabytes of data.
And the overall cost is
approximately $200,000.
But we have various
techniques that we
could have done to save cost.
And also, this is the
first time world records
were broken on the cloud
service, any cloud service,
and on SSD.
So all the past records
on PCs used hard drives.
And we also use the AVX-512,
the Intel's latest [INAUDIBLE]
extensions, which probably
saved the power consumption
during the calculation.
Why would you want to use cloud?
Suddenly, it's easier
to run the program.
You can run off-the-shelf
program without modifying it.
And it takes minutes
on the cluster.
we run 25 machines.
And it takes about a minute or
two to start these 25 machines.
It's much faster than
going to a hardware store
and building your own computer.
And also, it's more reliable.
Cloud tends to have fewer
hardware periods compared
to your desktop computers.
And we have mechanisms
to reduce failures.
And we line migrate [INAUDIBLE]
machines from one node
to another in the case of
maintenance, et cetera.
And even when there is hardware
failure, what you need to do
is only restart your instances.
So you have shorter
meantime to recover.
And operations are easier, too.
When you take backups with
your physical machine,
you need to copy your
entire hard drives.
But on cloud, you just
need to take snapshots.
And everything can
be done remotely.
I moved from Tokyo to
Seattle during the project.
But I didn't have to move
the physical machines.
And the calculation was running
in one of the data centers
with Google.
As we said, that
we had 25 machines.
But one of the machines
is the biggest machines,
which runs y-cruncher.
It has then the latest
Skylake processor
with 96vCPUs, 1.4
terabytes of RAM,
it ran Windows Server
because y-cruncher
is more optimized for Windows.
And it had 30 terabyte SSD
to store the final results.
And we needed 170 terabytes
of disk, 170, so 70 terabytes
of disk.
So we added 24 additional
nodes providing a storage
and bandwidth.
And each of them has 16vCPUs
with 60 gigabytes of RAM.
And they are just Linux
servers and iSCSI targets.
And we mounted the storage
nodes from the Windows Server.
When we were deciding
the main compute node,
there were a couple of factors.
First, having more
cores or faster CPUs
means more computational power.
So the calculation would
be done in less time.
And more memory means less I/O
because we can buffer and bring
more data out at once.
And we had two instance
types with the biggest
amount of memory.
One is n1-megamem-96
with 96 CPUs.
This is 2-socket Skylake system
with 1.40 terabytes of RAM.
And the other choice is
n1-ultramem-160 with 160 vCPUs.
This is a 4-socket
Broadwell system
with almost 4 terabytes of RAM.
We decide to go with the
n1-megamem-96 because it's
supports AVX-512,
as Alex said, it's
extension of the
Intel architecture.
And it's faster than the
previous generations.
And also, having
fewer sockets mean
there are fewer NUMA nodes.
That means there will be
less memory access overhead.
So actually n1-megamem-96 could
be as fast or maybe faster
than the 160 vCPU machine.
So we pick the first choice.
In order to store hundreds
of terabytes of data,
we needed to have network
attached to storage,
we're using iSCSI.
So you can now touch up to 64
terabytes of Persistent Disks
to One Compute Engine.
But we needed more.
So we had to attach these
disks separate from [INAUDIBLE]
structure.
So this is done on the
operating system level.
So it's not subject
to the limit.
And instead of
using hard drives,
that standard Persistent Disks,
we decided to go with the SSDs.
Because nobody has tried
using SSDs to calculate Pi.
They weren't record breaking Pi.
And to connect these
disks, we used y-crunchers
on RAID system.
The first reason is it's
optimized for y-cruncher,
so it's more efficient.
And the second
reason is when you
take snapshots you don't have to
worry about the synchronization
between disks.
If you set up a single
huge file system,
you may have to worry about
the metadata of the disk.
But when you have
different disks,
you don't have to
worry about it.
So I decided to use the
y-crunchers RAID layer.
And I run benchmark with 20,
24, 32 nodes and 24 nodes
seemed to perform the best.
So I pick 24.
It achieved 26 Gbps
read and 16 Gbps write.
So it's almost
the network limit.
There are additional tactics we
used to keep the [INAUDIBLE] up
and running.
The first one is
the iSCSI drives
are doing live migrations.
And of course,
backups and snapshots
are important for these
long running computations.
And we also set up monitoring.
The first point is
live migrations.
So Google Cloud,
especially Compute Engine,
live migrates virtual machines
from one node to another.
In the case of regular
infrastructure maintenance
and upgrades, network and
power grid maintenance
in the data centers, host
OS and the BIOS upgrades.
So when we perform these
kind of maintenances,
we migrate the
[INAUDIBLE] machines
so that we can perform
this maintenance
work without affecting the
guest operating system.
And these consist
of these gray areas.
It's hard to see, but
it's more than half
of the total of live migrations.
And small portion is the
possible hardware failures,
such as memory, CPU, network.
If we see early signs
of hardware failures,
we also migrate [INAUDIBLE]
machines to another machine.
And it usually finishes in
10s of microseconds to finish,
to move one node to the
other, but not for y-cruncher
or this kind of memory
intense workloads.
So this is the diagram
of live migrations.
So first we start
to copy the memory
from one node to the new node.
And then when we copy most
of the data, we stop the VM
and move state from the
old VM to the new VM,
and then restart the execution.
And if there is any outstanding
data pages on the old node,
we continue to copy the data
and finish the live migration.
So the middle is
the blackout period.
So we completely start VM, but
the other two parts, gray outs,
brown outs, so we
keep moving the VMs,
but we see a work in
another [INAUDIBLE]..
But the problem is
memory bandwidth
is almost always faster
than network bandwidth.
So it's a typical
2 socket machine,
you have probably 200 gigabytes
per second of memory bandwidth,
that means 1,600 Gbps, yes?
But the user network
is around 100 Gbps.
And y-cruncher could
rewrite 1.4 terabytes of RAM
in less than 15 seconds.
You would never catch
up copying the data.
And this diagram is memory
profiling results y-cruncher.
And the other is bandwidth
on the 1 socket machine
is more than 50
gigabytes per second.
So it's still faster
than the network.
During the live
migration we start the VM
and copy the essential
memory regions.
And then we start the VM.
So during the brownout
process, the VMs keep running.
But it just gets slower,
and in this case,
it took about 15 minutes to
finish the live migrations.
And for the record, the typical
live migration is much faster.
And in fact, 97%
of live migration
don't have the post
copy process at all.
So they copy everything
before they start the VM
or restart the VM.
And 99.25% of the duration
is 660 milliseconds.
So it's usually much faster.
So this is how y-cruncher is
an extreme workload on cloud.
And the default iSCSI
timeout value was too short.
So during the slow
brownout phase,
these drives actually
timed out and the migration
was disconnected.
So I had to increase the
timeout value to 900 seconds
so that these drives
won't get dismounted.
And backup was also
an important point.
So when you run
y-cruncher it always
automatically saves
checkpoints during calculation.
And you can restart
from these checkpoints
when, for example, the
hardware program crashes.
But these checkpoints are
overreaching asynchronously
each time.
So if you crashed
during checkpointing,
or if you take backups
during checkpointings,
these snapshots are not--
these checkpoints are
not necessarily complete.
So backups needs to be
taken outside these windows.
And we use Persistent
Disk Snapshots
to store the checkpoint
files in order
to make the process
more consistent.
I run scripts to make
the process automated.
And manually run the
script once or twice a week
when the y-cruncher program was
not running for checkpointing.
And backups are only useful--
if you haven't
restored from a backup,
that means you
don't have a backup.
So I actually
crashed the machines.
I stopped the program
and I made sure I
was able to restore from
one of the snapshots.
So I practiced some
disaster scenarios
before actually running
the main computation.
And using Persistent
Disk Snapshots
is actually compressed
for backups.
It automatically compresses
and stores incremental backups,
so it's very fast when
you have fewer changes.
For example, the copies of
the same disk size, each
of the disks is 10 terabytes.
But one generation
is 1.8 terabytes,
and the next generation is
only 2.6 or 2 megabytes, also.
And it's really fast.
It sometimes takes
less than 10 minutes
to copy 10 terabytes of--
200 terabytes, 240
terabytes of disks.
And it's also cost effective.
Even if you have 170
terabytes of data
it only costs $4500 a month.
It's much cheaper than the
regular persistent disks.
And as for monitoring, we set
up both Stackdriver and Datadog
monitoring, because
we wanted to explore.
And this is the actual dashboard
during the live creation.
So we put some CPU
numbers and disk numbers,
and we set alerts to go off
when individual host goes down
and the average CPU usage of
an hour of the compute node
was less than 1%.
So that means
y-crunchers have crashed
or there was something wrong
with the operating system.
And these alerts
worked really well.
And I share this
dashboard with Alex
so we could independently
check the progress
of the calculation.
So after the calculation,
in hindsight,
this might seem
like a simple task
of running a program that you
downloaded from the internet
for four months.
But before we began, yes--
before we began, we
didn't know that we
could calculate this many number
of digits with network drives
or on cloud.
And we didn't know that a single
VM can run for four months
under heavy load.
Nobody-- maybe somebody
did, but we didn't know.
And nobody did
try the y-cruncher
with network strives for
this large calculations.
And network drives are
also able to handle
these kind of heavy I/Os.
So these are some
learnings we had.
And now we know it's
possible to run these kinds
of heavy workloads on cloud.
And that's great.
You can serve your own programs
with the cloud, not necessarily
Pi.
ALEXANDER YEE: So now I'm
going to talk about y-cruncher.
So we've thrown that name around
a gazillion times already.
Y-cruncher is the
program that we
used to compute
this thing, which
I wrote over the past too long.
So what is it?
It's a desktop application
for Windows and Linux
running primarily
on x86 and x64.
It can compute
mathematical constants
to extremely high precision,
billions, trillions of digits.
What can it compute?
Pretty much all the
major constants, Pi,
e, Golden Ratio,
Euler's Constant.
And the latest version can
actually do custom formulas.
So if you want to compute
the square root of Pi,
sure, have at it.
If you hate Pi and you're a tau
person, yeah, it will do it.
Primary uses.
It's mostly for
benchmarking PCs.
I'm a big part of the computer
building and overclocking
community.
And so I kind of
wrote this program
both for myself and everyone
else in the community.
And so I have a whole bunch of
machines at home overclocked.
And, yeah, I use my own software
to test my own hardware.
So, yeah, for benchmarking
and for stress-testing,
which is the other half
of enthusiast PC building.
And lastly, of course, is to set
records for all the constants.
To date, it set the
Pi record six times.
Plus it holds the
records for pretty much
all the other major constants.
And so this screenshot
is just a simple--
I think it's hard to see--
a snapshot of the program
computing 10 billion digits
of Pi on my computer.
So history of y-cruncher.
This thing goes
back way too far.
I'm not sure I should
admit it, but--
so 2006 April, APCS
high school class
of my senior year,
the project was
to write a 4 function
calculator in Java.
And after that thing finished,
I kept working on it.
It was fun.
And so over the summer I added
new features like square roots,
trig functions, constants.
And then I started optimizing
it for performance.
So I added a JNI C backend.
At some point I
started to realize
that some of the features
were actually faster
than commercially available
products like Mathematica.
One of which was the
Euler-Mascheroni Constant.
And so that year, my
freshman year of college,
I computed 116 million digits
of the Euler-Mascheroni Constant
for what I thought was a
world record at the time.
Turns out it wasn't.
Someone had 2 billion digits,
but they hadn't announced it,
yet.
And so, yeah, that
was kind of a letdown.
But anyway, school took over.
I didn't do anything
in 2007 because I
have schoolwork to do.
But then 2008, while I was in
one of my really boring lecture
classes--
I'm a terrible
student by the way--
I wasn't really
paying attention,
and so I kind of came
across a new algorithm
for performing large
multiplication.
I didn't really believe it at
first, but after some analysis
I realized it actually solved
a long standing problem that
prevented the existing
algorithms from benefiting
significantly from parallelism.
And so I still
didn't believe it.
So I went ahead and
implemented this thing.
And I finally realized,
oh my god, this thing
is actually for real.
So for that reason alone, I
read implemented everything
from scratch since
I'm natively in C,
and I built a really, really
big computer, this time
to try again for this record.
And so next year, sure
enough my roommate and I,
we computed 14.9
billion digits of
the Euler-Mascheroni Constant.
This time it was a world record,
and that's when I officially
named it y-cruncher.
Y being the gamma symbol for
the Euler-Mascheroni Constant
to the right.
Since then, later that year,
my roommate and I basically
swept the constants list.
Basically because of the
multiplication algorithm,
what we had was
essentially a cheat code
that no one else had in a
multi-player online game.
So it's an unfair
advantage that I exploited
to the maximum possible
fullest extent,
being somewhat of a gamer--
I used to be.
So 2010 was when I started
to add out-of-core support.
So I mentioned the word
out-of-core earlier.
Out-of-core is the ability
to use disk storage
to do computation when you
don't have enough memory.
And so after that was added,
I went ahead and computed
500 billion digits of e.
That was a new world record.
And then later that
year, I joined up
with Shigeru Kondo of Japan,
and he, with his much bigger
computers, basically swept
the remaining constants
sqrt(2), Golden Ratio, and e, as
well as Pi itself, the big one.
The only one that
really matters.
Since then, I've
since left school.
I don't have as
much time anymore,
so it's mostly been
incremental improvements,
minor improvements like
optimizations, enhancements.
It's been rewritten once.
The program has been used
to set five more Pi records.
As well as most of
the other constants.
And during this time,
I started refocusing
the program towards the
overclocking community.
Adding new features
for stress-testing,
and benchmarking,
and validation.
And so people actually
use the program
for competitive benchmarking--
competitive overclocking.
What is it like today?
Y-cruncher is half a
million lines of C++,
no longer heavily developed,
because I have a job now.
And I'm doing some research with
cluster and super-computing,
but realistically
speaking, that probably
isn't going to happen
given that I don't
have as much time as I used to.
So to the right is
the computer that I
built with my roommate
in 2008 to set
the first set of records.
So features of y-cruncher.
First of all, it uses mostly
state-of-the-art algorithms.
I'm not actually going
to talk about in detail
of any of these, because
you can easily Google them.
Because it would take me weeks
to literally go into all this
stuff.
But I use the Fast
Fourier Transforms
for large multiplication, binary
splitting for series summation,
and Newton's Method for
division and square root.
The program is parallelized
and it is NUMA-aware.
So it will be able
to utilize really
big machines with
hundreds of cores.
On the macro
optimization front, it
can use all the latest
Instruction Set Architecture
extensions like
SSE, AVX, AVX-512.
On the memory side, it has
tons of cache and memory
optimizations to
tackle the memory wall.
And then to get over the memory
limit, as I mentioned earlier,
it has out-of-core computation
to use disk storage
to overcome the memory limit.
And lastly, which is actually
more important than it sounds,
is fault tolerance.
One is the ability
for the application.
to save its state so
you can resume it later
in the event of an interruption.
That's called checkpointing.
And the other one
is software error
detection to detect
errors that happened
during the computation that are
not detected by the hardware.
So implementation
details of y-cruncher.
So as I said, I've been
working on this thing
on and off for 10 years now.
It's half a million
lines of code.
I cannot go into
every portion of it.
I'll be here for a year.
So I'm going to focus
on three parts that
are most likely of interest
to the audience that's here.
Namely the out-of-core
computation,
how do I utilize
disks for computation?
How do I do checkpointing?
And how do I do fault tolerance?
So out-of-core computation.
Motivation.
Not enough memory.
No PC to date has
160 terabytes of RAM.
And when they do in
a couple of decades,
your browser is going to end
up using all of it anyway.
So that isn't really--
yeah, that's not going to help.
Conceptually, use
disk as memory.
Each C++ object
is a file on disk.
And use RAM as just
the cache for disk.
And so all the data actually
logically lives on disk.
And if you want to do
any computation on it,
you have to manually bring
it into memory, do your work,
and then write it back.
In other words, this is
a form of manual paging.
So what are the
difficulties of this?
Disk is very slow.
A disk seek is tens
of milliseconds
a cache miss to memory is on
the order of 100 nanoseconds.
So there is quite a few
orders of magnitude there.
And so you can't just take an
algorithm written for memory,
and just put it on the disk.
It's not going to--
you'll be here for
the rest of your life.
Secondly, because of all
the explicit data transfers,
there's a significant
amount of coding complexity.
Likewise, there are
separate implementations
for in-memory and out-of-core.
So much of the code is
actually duplicated twice.
It's written twice.
And lastly, the last thing you
need with all its complexity
is something to get in the
way like the operating system.
And so you have to fight it.
I'll get into that.
So this picture here is
Shigeru Kondo's computer,
which he used to set
the record back in 2012.
He had lots of hard
drives, lots of red cables.
This is amazing for a
computer enthusiast like me.
Fighting the operating system.
2009 was when I started doing--
when I started implementing
the out-of-core stuff.
On Windows you have to
defeat the OS disk caching.
If you allocate a
large file on disk,
and then you start accessing it
the way that y-cruncher does,
Windows is going to page--
it's going to try
so hard to cache
that it will page
itself out of memory.
And so nothing-- the
whole system just freezes.
Your mouse won't move.
Your keyboard won't respond.
It's just hangs there.
And so the only way to
save it-- well not save it
is to hit the reset button.
And so after fighting
this for a long time,
the only way to
actually solve this
is to tell the Windows
to get out of the way.
And so in other words, do
the buffering yourself.
Which means I have to
deal with all the sector
alignment, the read, modify,
write, manage my own buffers.
Again, adding even more
complexity to the program.
Secondly, is security zeroing.
So if you allocate a 1
terabyte file on disk,
and you write to the end of
it, what happens in Windows
is that it will actually zero
the entire file from start
to finish.
So what should be an ON,
essentially free operation
to 1 byte at the end of a
file, ends up taking hours.
Because you're watching
the hard drive just
grind through the entire
file to get to the end.
This is, needless to say, not
acceptable from a performance
standpoint.
Why does the OS do it?
Because the contents of the disk
are going to contain deleted
stuff from previous files.
And so if you have a password
there that's been deleted,
self-deleted, and then you
allocate a large file on it
without zeroing it, you
cannot access that data.
And so it's actually a
security vulnerability.
And so the only way to
bypass that zeroing is
to obtain privilege elevation.
But it took me a long
time to figure out
that I had to do that.
2010 was when I poured
the program to Linux.
And so I had to fight a
different set of OS issues.
And Linux, the failure cases
were less egregious on Windows.
At least it wouldn't
hang your system,
and freeze it, and
require a hard reset.
But overall, I was
never able to achieve
the level of performance and
controls I could in Windows.
For example, on Windows I
bypassed the disk I/O cache
by using a special flag.
And it always respects it.
If it doesn't, it fails
the API call and so I know.
On Linux, the equivalent
flag is called O_DIRECT.
Sometimes the kernel
will respect it.
Sometimes it doesn't.
It might pass, but
doesn't really respect it.
And so in the end, the program
doesn't know, in the end
you get hit with sometimes
a large performance hit.
So the next topic is
application checkpointing.
The ability to save and
resume application state.
Motivations.
OK.
This computation took 121 days.
There is no way this thing
is staying up for 121 days.
Things are going to crash.
There might be bugs
in the program.
Power might go out.
If you forget to
disable Windows updates,
that will screw you over, too.
I know.
And so there is a
very high probability
that it's not going to run all
the way through in one run.
And so the difficulties of
saving the state is that one,
there is a very
complex program state.
Like I said, it's half
a million lines of C++.
There is a long execution stack.
There are recursive
algorithms all over
the place, hundreds
of functions.
There's no built in mechanism
in C++ to do checkpointing
for you.
And lastly, there
is a huge data set.
This computation required
160 terabytes of data.
And if checkpointing means
copying that data somewhere
else, and your checkpoints
are five minutes apart,
you're not getting
any work done.
You're just copying
data the whole time.
And so the first thing,
the most important thing,
is to actually get rid of
the overhead checkpointing.
Which is to integrate it with
the out-of-core computation.
So as I mentioned before,
in out-of-core computation,
C++ objects are
files on the disk.
And so checkpointing is
simply renaming the file
and then write protecting it.
So that's essentially
zero overhead.
And then secondly, it is
to actually checkpoint only
when the disk usage
is relatively low.
So while the program--
so while the computation
needs 160 terabytes
of disk, most of the time,
it's actually less than 50.
But it's just those
occasional spikes
that actually hit those
limits that actually
cause it to be so high.
And so if I strategically
checkpoint when it's low,
then we don't need as
much backup storage
to store the checkpoints.
OK.
Checkpointing in C++.
How do I do it?
It's a total hack.
I don't claim this is the
best way, but it works.
And if it ain't
broken, don't fix it.
So I explicitly maintain a
copy of the execution stack.
When I enter the
function, when I
enter a function that is
running in out-of-core mode,
I call into the
checkpointing framework
and it tells it that I'm
entering a new function
for a new stack frame.
And so therefore, I have
the state separately
that I can use to
serialize on checkpoints.
For program flow itself, I abuse
fall-through switch statements.
Essentially, when the
program is running normally,
it runs through the
switch statements
as if the cases weren't there.
And then when you're loading
from a checkpoint, the moment
you start the function, you
call into the framework,
it tells you what
to jump to and boom.
I'm here.
And so it skips everything.
At each case, I have to
declare all the live variables
in that stack frame, which is
unfortunately very manual, very
error prone.
So I spend a lot
of time manually
testing all this stuff.
But once I had this sort
of programming idiom set,
it was very easy to extend it to
pretty much the entire program.
So the example here
is the actual code
from the implementation
of e, slightly modified
for this presentation.
The comments have been
changed to explain
the checkpointing as opposed
to the algorithm itself.
Fault tolerance.
OK, in long running
computations, as I mentioned,
things are going to break.
Checkpointing allows you to
pause, resume, and backup.
But it doesn't
catch silent errors.
So silent hardware
errors, they are a thing.
Y-cruncher has been used to
set the Pi record six times.
Four of them have had
hardware errors, two of them,
two of those actually had
silent hardware errors.
And so silent hardware
errors, it doesn't blue
screen your computer,
it doesn't crash it,
it doesn't quit the program.
It just corrupts your data,
and so it's all wrong.
And so if that happens, you'll
get to the end of computation
and the digits will be wrong.
And so you've wasted everything.
It can happen for a
number of reasons--
CPU memory, disk controller.
And so the only solution here
is to build error detection
into the software.
And once you catch some
errors, retry, and then resume
from the checkpoint.
So here is an example of a
typical divide and conquer
algorithm.
If you detect a
fault on this node,
just redo the whole block.
No big deal.
So how do I do software
error detection?
It's mostly on a
case by case basis.
There's generally two types
of these, sanity checks
and deterministic checks.
Sanity checks are low overhead.
They don't catch all errors.
Deterministic checks, they
tend to be more expensive,
but they will catch all
errors with high probability.
Examples.
If I want to check to see
if any data is corrupted,
I can hash it before and
after the usage period.
And if they hash the
same thing, it probably
hasn't been corrupted.
That's a deterministic check.
That's expensive.
You use two different formulas
to calculate the same constant.
If the formulas are
completely independent,
and they share no work,
that will catch all--
if they don't match then that
means something is wrong.
So that will actually catch
all errors, both hardware
and software.
And then we get to the
more domain specific things
like Newton's
Method convergence.
Newton's Method, for those of
you who are familiar with it,
involves iterating an
algorithm until it converges.
Well, if it doesn't converge,
you know something's wrong.
And so, yeah.
Modular residuals.
If you're doing integer
arithmetic, addition,
subtraction, multiplication,
you can actually
keep a modulus of the large
numbers over a prime number,
and propagate that along
with these large numbers.
Because modular
arithmetic is closed
under those three operations.
So you can do a whole
bunch of large operations
and then check the
residuals at the end.
This is deterministic, and
it's relatively inexpensive.
The last one is the
most obscure of them.
It's hard for me to
explain, but it is also
the most important
one in the program.
It is the check, the coefficient
sizes in a Fast Fourier
Transform.
So long story short,
Fast Fourier Transforms
are used for large
multiplication.
It's used for a
polynomial multiplication.
Based on the sizes
of the inputs,
you can prove how
large the outputs
will be for each coefficient.
And if anything is bigger than
that, you know it's wrong.
This one has pretty
much 100% test coverage
of a large multiplication,
which is pretty much
probably 90% of the computation
in the Pi computation.
So what's the scope?
Error detection catches
90% of the hardware errors
from empirical testing.
Which is good, but not something
that you could rely on.
But on the flip side
of that, it also
catches software bugs,
because the error detection,
it doesn't distinguish
between software error bugs.
So what we have here
is self-testing code
which allows me to be lazy.
And so if I'm writing
something that I
know is going to have
100% coverage by a higher
level error detection check, I
don't even bother testing it.
Write it and then let the code
higher up deal with it later.
And so this is an
example of the program
failing on an error check.
So, future work.
As far as y-cruncher, the
program is in a steady state
now.
I don't really have any
major future plans for it.
It's just a hobby that I
work on every now and then.
I'll continue to make
incremental improvements.
And as I mentioned
earlier, there's
some ongoing research
on scalability.
How do I make this thing
scale better on NUMA?
On cluster computing
and super-computing?
But there's very little
effort going into that.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
And for cloud itself,
we will continue to
have better hardware.
We will be able to
target more digits.
We just announced instance
with 12 terabytes of RAM.
That's huge.
And for other
types of workloads,
we prove that cloud
is capable of doing
mathematical large
scale computations.
So we plan to find and solve
more compute intensive use
cases.
[MUSIC PLAYING]